in terms of basic skills and natural
gifts how does one know they should be a
screenwriter it's a great great question
and amazing to us how few people ask
that question you know people decide
they want to be a screenwriter because
they like movies way too often or maybe
they don't even like movies but they
just had an idea that they thought could
be a moving movie there there's so
there's not enough of people stepping
back and saying what are the essential
skills of this field and do I have them
and do I have them in like the top ten
percent or even five percent you know
and am I willing to hang in there long
enough to develop yeah you know I think
the number right now is 2% of the
members of the Writers Guild of America
make a living as screenwriters so that
means 98% are doing other things too you
know and so so but we think this comes
back to just um failure to really stand
back and say what natural abilities
should I have to be a good screenwriter
right so right off the top we you have
you got to have what we call a honed
story sense a honed story sense this is
somebody who has instincts about story
and we don't know where you get this
except from having read a lot of stories
you know so one of the things we say all
the time is great writers are great
readers you know so you you want to get
a hot you want to get good instincts
about a great character well you do this
by reading the Arabian Nights and the
Greek myths and the Brothers Grimm and
the Arthurian tales and and Count of
Monte Cristo and then as you move up you
know the read read the Russians read
read the great novels read Dickens and
and the Bronte's like you should be as a
storyteller somebody who is in the
company of storytellers
has your preferred place to be and
you've probably been devouring this your
whole life
and this is something that is developed
you know from kindergarten on is this a
sense of always wanting to be in story
and I think that that's a natural
inclination that that speaks well to you
know a screenwriting career story is
like instinct you know either this is
this is a high-stakes choice this is a
real crucible situation some people have
that instinct and some people don't and
with they don't have it you know you're
sitting there trying to it's like trying
to explain to a duck why they should fly
south really hard okay no they they just
don't get it and and so we when we meet
somebody like that that has no instincts
in story we know I just want to tell
them you know in fact we give them a
list of the hundred most influential
stories ever written
and I say go read you know start
knocking these off one a month and in
five years you'll be ready and I would
say the difference between say a
novelist and a screenwriter is a scream
in addition to all of these great books
screenwriters also watch a lot of movies
they've seen all the classics they are
up on what are you know what all the
Academy Award winners are for that year
and they they have a good sense of
what's going on in theirs onra that
they're interested in they're just
constantly taking in and and they're
also reading scripts it's really
important for screenwriters to read
what's on the written page in in
screenplay form because that's going to
say so much about it's really just going
to speak to everything that they need to
know technically about how to tell a
story and on the screen I mean it's like
an essential skill that you got to have
is a sense of the moment that movies are
combinations of beats and moments right
beats are something happens in the plot
somebody makes a choice and it leads to
this consequence so that's part of the
story sense you know a choice something
happening but moments are the emotional
stakes underlying that choice so you
know when you think of a movie like
Titanic you know what's the moment ah
those two standing on the bow everybody
can see that moment right I'm the king
of the world right but that was a great
great moment that resonated with people
so having a sense of where are the
moments in my movie one of the
complaints that that we hear in the
notes we hear from people about movies
day right and the subtext complaint is I
just sat through a two hour movie where
there were no moments there was a lot of
beats a lot of stuff happened but I
never felt an emotional kind of plateau
I'm you know an emotional peak in this
movie I never felt like I wanted to
laugh or I wanted to cry or I felt
outraged like I never felt that so this
idea of a writer having kind of an a gut
sense of what makes a peak emotional
moment you know what what is that death
cycle and it's a psychological thing
it's a psychological dynamic so the
writer needs to be a psychologist and be
able to say in my story where the two or
three key emotional moments that I need
to like take like the movie the pace
needs to slow down and we're gonna
really go into it and kind of saturate
the audience in this in this experience
emotionally really have them crescendo
in this kind of weather whatever the if
it's patos if it's you know sadness if
it's anger if it's fear whatever it is
and so a lot of times when I'll say to
that writers you know what are the key
moments in your movie and they'll be
looking to like you know when the start
when the ship sinks it's like no it's
not when the ship sinks it's when the
ship sinks and note that does to her you
know the character etc so so letting it
land in a sense it's not because I see a
lot of stuff today that it almost goes
there but it's move so fast keeps moving
yeah yeah and and I would say with
independent film you you also have the
reverse problem where if you have too
many moments it's not going anywhere
you're just sitting there watching
people in moat and and and then there's
no pace there's no dramatic tension and
that in that regard he just fizzles out
but yes you know I think that there's
you know both of them are are dangers
for sure and you know we have we have we
list actually seven in our book
essential skills for screenwriters I
think those are the two you know key
ones there but but you know the main
thing is that to approach this field as
you know something that you have been
made to do because of your natural gifts
you don't just do it because you you're
like the glamour of the business or the
Hollywood thing you know all of that
stuff you know no you do it because you
were made to do this because the gifts
you have are geared towards this and so
one of the things we do in mentoring
writers at catharsis is to help them try
to figure that out you know do you have
the chops to do this professionally or
is it going to be a hobby for you
because there's raw talent there's
natural incan inclinations but then
there's also ten years of hard work of
applying skills and building on skills
and really strengthening your muscles
and being able to be the right person to
tackle the project and that's a
long-term investment it's a marathon and
it really does take both in order to
have a career and you know and I would
say you can have the skill set level
also determines where you're gonna play
in this business right so you know I
have a sister she's a professional opera
singer and just like you know the top 2%
of opera singers sing at the Met you
know the top 10% sing in San Francisco
Denver you know Chicago the top 20% sing
in Portland you know see ya you know
Seattle whatever so in other words it's
possible to be a dramatic writer of
writing for the screen but not
necessarily playing at the Hollywood
studio level you can be writing web
series content that will get an audience
of a hundred thousands or even the tens
of thousands your skill sets can take
you there you can be in the indie world
where you're you know you'll get in your
lifetime three checks for twenty
thousand dollars for different projects
right but you can make a little movie
that will get seen by you know tens of
thousands of people and a few festivals
I think that you don't have to say if I
can't play it at the top level that I
can't play at all so one of the things
we try to do in our mentoring of the
writers figure out where your skill set
is gonna put you what percent where do
you fall in you know in terms of the
most influence the most impact the most
money
how are you competing cuz again don't
set yourself up for failure if you're
only in the top 10% of writers then
don't try to play in a field where the
top 2% are going to be the one
to make a living out of it and screen
storytelling is so diversified now that
there's no reason to not find your niche
at this point so
you